foreign
of all the rabbit holes I get stuck in
on the internet I don't know any quite
as powerful as Google Earth
[Music]
seeing beautiful patterns from above
dropping down into street view and
seeing the planet in ways I would never
get to see in person
[Music]
so when I came across this post on
Reddit I was fascinated it described
undocumented markings in Algeria in the
middle of the Sahara near a location
called tebellat tomb visible on Google
Earth there were 22 of them each with 12
surrounding things 42 meters in diameter
420 meters apart at longitude 420 East
it almost sounded like a joke but then I
copied the coordinates and I looked
[Music]
there they weren't identical circles in
an almost perfect line 160 kilometers
from any signs of life in the world's
largest desert in the middle of the
biggest country in Africa
this is a story about the limits of what
you can find out on the internet about
all the different ways of looking at the
same thing and about going all the way
there
over the course of the last 20 weeks we
filmed every step of the process as we
tried to figure out one thing
what could these circles be
[Music]
okay so this whole story starts back in
September 2021 when I first saw this
Reddit post I wanted to figure out what
these markings were and make a video out
of the entire reporting process no
matter how long it took because the
answer had to be out there and step one
I knew I was gonna have to send some
emails for weeks I reached out to
everyone I could think of Algerian
experts officials tour groups even the
closest hotel in a city called insala I
read up on the town the circles were
located closest to bogara izuya I asked
the commenters on the Reddit post and we
even tracked down a Twitter account we
thought was the same will K who posted
this question to several subreddits
before deleting their Reddit account I
tried English and French organizations
academics locals and then
I waited
oh but there was one easy thing to clear
up first
were these circles real or were they
just some kind of satellite imaging
glitch so I asked a teammate who works
with maps a lot Sam he produces our
series Alice and he pointed me to the
company that takes a lot of the
satellite pictures for Google Earth
maxar Technologies
I feel very confident that those are
indeed on the ground and because we see
them in multiple images over multiple
years so I know it wasn't an artifact of
the processing that Google would have
done with our imagery and then a
colleague of mine who has spent a decent
amount of time studying this area said
you know this is a very rich area for
oil and gas this looks very similar to
what we see when they're doing oil
exploration
oil radically changed the course of
algeria's history oil from the
wastelands of the desert and it's
believed that the Sahara is immensely
rich in it when oil and gas were first
discovered there in 1956 companies
flocked to the region against the
backdrop of a brutal decolonization war
with France today Algeria is one of the
world's top exporters of natural gas
what Steve is talking about here are
seismic surveys where geophysicists
analyze the Earth's surface by sending
shock waves into the ground depending on
how those seismic waves bounce back
researchers can tell what resources can
be extracted from underground Steve
thought that maybe seismic Pulses from a
specialized vehicle could produce
something like this
so we had a hypothesis but I wanted a
second opinion so I asked Bob hardage at
the University of Texas he's one of the
world's leading experts on seismic
Imaging he responded by email I can
assure you with a hundred percent
confidence that the features in this
imagery are not seismic arrays used in
oil and gas exploration first the shapes
themselves weren't right there will be
hundreds of thousands of receivers
positioned as either a single straight
line or as hundreds of parallel straight
lines I looked up pictures from NASA of
seismic surveying and you can see what
he means second the fact that we could
even see them meant that they probably
weren't a seismic survey the objective
is to leave the landscape like you found
it if a seismic crew created something
like these features a return visit would
be made to restore the landscape I have
no idea what these circles in the
satellite image are whatever they are
the people who created them wanted those
features to be permanent
close out I don't think we need to chat
thanks Bob
so I kept Googling I found geotagged
pictures from the nearest municipality
fagara izuya on a site called mapio.net
These Old Stone Wells sort of look like
they could be arranged in a circle but
reverse image searches were a dead end
I didn't know what to do next so we
looped in fox videos senior researcher
Melissa to help me out so I was trying
to find what this thing was I don't know
if you remember from his original post
he calls it the tibal ballet tomb do you
remember that yeah so I I found this
article this is from like
1985 I mean not 19 1885 1885. yeah The
Well of tabal ballet is at the latitude
27 degrees 20 and longitude 4 degrees 38
and that's approximately where what
we're looking at is and it says there
are two circular tumuli
um I had to Google that I don't know
that word
that's a tumulus tumulus it's an ancient
burial mound a which seems like that
sounds about right yeah encompassed by
two concentric Mounds in the form of
rings all of great regularity the two
rings are respectively 30 and 21 meters
in diameter from Crest to Crest well
wow so a document from 1885 said that
around the same area there were one a
bunch of wells and two tombs with rings
of great regularity now the sketches
weren't an exact match but they got us
thinking
what if these things were actually
really old so I sent the pictures to a
Tunisian archaeologist who had done
research in this area we spoke in French
because of Decades of French occupation
in the 19th and 20th centuries French is
still used in many contexts in Tunisia
and Algeria and she had a new clue
a
foreign
it's the North African name for a 2500
year old style of irrigation system that
goes by many names but is often called a
cannot Builders dig a well at an
elevated point on a slope deep enough to
tap into groundwater they then dig
parallel shafts at regular intervals and
these provide airflow for diggers as
they create an underground Channel all
the way back to the main well with a
slope of one or two degrees the channel
carries water long distances powered by
gravity alone in a part of the world
with barely any rain and no running
Rivers this technology provides water
for crops and livestock and people year
round making human-made oases possible
this was the most promising lead yet it
explained the Desert location the
circular shape the regularity and
spacing even the closest municipality
fogarezuya is named after phogares and
those mapio images of Wells started to
make a lot of sense but I wanted to run
it by more people who had studied
cannots
are
very raisin Beatrice they're the kind of
basis of inhabitation in such kind of
harsh climates they start from outskirt
of the city but then they usually end up
into the city or into agricultural lands
but when it came to our circles I have
no take on it honestly yeah
[Music]
oh yeah I'm looking at it now right okay
that's interesting there's something
like 20 of them yeah yeah so that's
definitely a Fogata so at the end of
that there should be a town there should
be an oasis or something but if it isn't
that means that probably the water is I
mean the cannot or the forget it has
dried up you should talk to uh Dale
Lightfoot he is the American geographer
who knows everything about canads these
are what we're looking at I don't I I
couldn't even say with confidence
whether these are related to water
collection
but I can tell you they're definitely
not cannots
we also found these pictures do you
think these could be what the circles
are what you're showing me pictures of
here
looks a lot like just uh animal drawn
well I've seen these in a lot of places
to me this is not the same thing I think
you're back to square one back to square
one indeed don't realize spaces I've
heard they do crazy things too
so they might be Wells but probably not
a cannot
and maybe not even related to water at
all
could we at least rule that out that's
when Melissa found a database of Oasis
in the Sahara with lists of the people
who helped manage their water supply
like Muhammad brick a former in laguat
Algeria
uh
population
[Music]
we were three months in and it seemed
like our most promising hypothesis yet
was probably out
then I got an email
back in early October Steve Wood
promised to send me high-res images from
maxar's archive finally we had them
it was the clearest look we'd had yet
and Steve believed it showed a new
detail
tire tracks if that was right it would
mean someone had been there within the
last century
I kept asking people historians Algerian
officials archaeologists and nearby
residents
but after a while I felt stuck
like we had exhausted what we could find
out on the internet and there was
nowhere else to go from here except to
the circles themselves
the longer this project went on the more
I realized we had a choice to make we
could keep interviewing more and more
people get more and more theories and
ultimately have no way to back any of
them up
or we could try to get someone there
try to film it and then maybe we could
know for sure
so I asked my teammate Christina who
works with journalists all over the
world if she knew anyone in Algeria and
that led us to Samir ABC a video
journalist in Algiers
we hired Samir to be our on the ground
journalist to use his expertise in the
area to help us solve this mystery the
next part took months
we knew this wasn't going to be an
ordinary video shoot we were asking him
and his team to travel incredibly far to
go do something potentially dangerous
but Samir took the story into his own
hands he was obsessing over every
hypothesis and setting up local contacts
and figuring out all the details of how
to get a team of people from Algiers 15
hours away by car to insula and then
deep into the desert where no roads go
finally Samir figured out how to make it
happen
and at 7 pm on a cool February night he
and his second cameraman ablati set off
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
soda
something called
they'd already spent 24 hours driving to
get there now they had to go another 160
kilometers from ensala into the desert
but they had to pick up someone else
first Fareed Eagle haris an
archaeologist who used to lead algeria's
National archaeological research center
and managed one of algeria's largest
national parks he's here to help the
team identify whatever they come across
from there they prepared
they got groceries bought fuel
interviewed local officials planned the
GPS route and they assembled a team a
driver an archaeologist an assistant and
a desert guide
[Music]
it's right about here that I lost
communication with Samir and I wouldn't
be able to hear from him until he was
back in town with hopefully a definitive
answer
[Music]
yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna pick it up
what's weird is that as the crew got
closer and closer they started finding
signs pointing to every one of our
theories
[Music]
first tire marks from seismic survey
trucks
then a well system
and finally ancient tombs
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
after 160 kilometers of driving off-road
in the desert they were there the 22
circles all in configuration
they were surprisingly faint you might
not notice them if you happen to be
passing by
as Samir and the team explored the area
they found the next set and the next
ones
the Twitter
[Music]
and a lot of them had something in
common
metal wires
[Music]
under these little Mounds was Dynamite
foreign
that's a French acronym for the Tunisian
company of explosives and ammunition
but one of the wires looks different
than the others it still had a yellow
plastic coating
this is where it got a little scary
I guess
follows
eventually they decided that the
dynamite if there was any left was
probably harmless because it would have
needed a Detonator to go off
so they started to dig
but it was buried quite deep so at some
point to be safe they stopped
and then they found a clue no one could
have expected
to
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
all right
so we knew what it was Dynamite buried
underground and when Samir and the crew
finally got home I called him to hear
all the details
we think that we have we know the the
solution
look but it was an old technique
oh at the very beginning of this journey
that's one of the first things that
anyone ever suggested is that it had to
do with searching for petroleum
which is crazy that it's finally
confirmed it's the same thing that they
do today just with dynamite instead of
you know more finely tuned technology
this is this is crazy this is so much
more wild than I expected ironically it
put us right back where we started
seismic surveying these circles are the
remnants of surveyors looking for
resources underground this whole time
that first guess was right
but only sort of because Bob hardage at
the University of Texas was right when
he said in that email that this doesn't
remotely resemble seismic surveying
because this isn't what seismic
surveying looks like today it's an older
technique from the early days of
surveying that uses Dynamite explosions
instead of vibration machines the
explosions would provide the seismic
waves that would reflect and refract off
of the ground underneath and that would
tell surveyors that something
potentially something valuable like oil
was underground and worth digging for
the circles looked like this because of
the force of those Dynamite explosions
happening Underground
From This Moment a new question came
what who did this and when yeah knowing
it was a seismic survey wasn't enough
but we had one more clue from the desert
to turn to
the Sardine cans
[Music]
I reached out to Sophie K which seems to
be the only one of these companies that
still exists but they said they couldn't
identify their age by photos so I found
someone who's been collecting sardine
cans for over 40 years Philippe angino
he even made a museum out of it and I
showed him the pictures
[Music]
so because this can is labeled Arsen
soapy K we know that it was manufactured
before they changed their name in 1960
because of its 60s style three body
design we know that it's probably from
the very late 1950s granted this is
canned food so it's possible that it was
purchased years before it was actually
eaten but I think it's safe to Guess
that these cans were left behind by an
oil exploration crew sometime in the
late 1950s all that was left was to
figure out who those people were
before going into the desert Samir
recorded interviews with the experts
that they met along the way and there
was one interview with someone who
actually would have been there in the
late 1950s the father of the desert
guides who used to work as a desert
guide himself
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
craps a French acronym for the Sahara
petroleum research and exploitation
company was a joint venture between the
French government and shell Krebs had a
permit to explore and extract oil in
this entire expanse of the Sahara from
1953 to 1958. lining up that map with
Google Maps shows that the circles are
inside that krep sector and according to
these French Senate records they started
geological surveys right away within
that time kreps became the first company
to strike oil in the Sahara in ejele in
1956. this bird A Rush of oil companies
into the region and the struggle over
control of Saharan oil became a
centerpiece of France's brutal war
against Algerian Independence
it was the end of nearly eight years of
Bloodshed and the African nation won its
freedom after 132 years even when
Algeria won its independence in 1962
France maintained rights to Saharan oil
for years to come these circles are
scars of colonialism they're evidence of
one country's attempts to take the
resources of another and they're only as
isolated as they are because oil wasn't
found there everywhere that it was was
transformed forever
[Music]
so
we figured it out these circles in the
Sahara were left behind by French crepes
employees looking for oil they were made
by underground Dynamite explosions
arranged in circles along a straight
line through the desert and based on the
dates of the krep's permit and the type
of cans that they left behind we can
safely guess that they were there around
1957 or 1958.
when we figured it all out I emailed Bob
and he said this you have certainly done
a persistent and thorough investigation
I am comfortable with the conclusion
that your features are remnants of
decades-old first generation analog
recording of seismic data an
unbelievable preservation comparing
1950s seismic equipment and today's
seismic equipment is similar to
comparing propeller airplanes and deep
space Rockets essentially there is no
comparison but two different worlds
well done
thanks Bob
[Music]
we only know this thanks to the help of
dozens of people someone's 65 year old
trash a lot of time on the internet and
a long Brave journey into the desert of
course a story like this could always
keep going more and more specific but at
some point to finish a story we have to
ask ourselves if the answer that we have
is satisfactory
and I think this one is
[Music]
foreign